Bien, qui suis-je ?
En général je dis aux gens, quand ils demandent, "Que faites-vous dans la vie ?"
Je dis: «Je fabrique du matériel»,
parce que ça couvre tout ce que je fais et c'est pratique.
Et j'ai dit ça récemment à un spécialiste du capital-risque sur un ton informel
lors d'un évènement à Silicon Vallée, et il a répondu: «Comme c'est pittoresque."
(Rires)
Et ça m'a vraiment sidéré.
Et j'aurais vraiment dû dire quelque chose d'intelligent.
Et maintenant que j'ai eu un peu de temps pour y réfléchir,
je dirais : «Eh bien, vous savez,
si nous considérons les 100 prochaines années
et nous avons vu tous ces problèmes dans les derniers jours,
la plupart des grandes questions - l'eau potable, l'énergie propre -
et ils sont interchangeables, à certains égards -
des matériaux plus propre et plus fonctionnels -
ils ressemblent tous pour moi à des problèmes de matériaux.
Cela ne signifie pas que nous devrions ignorer les logiciels,
ou l'information, ou le calcul.
Et c'est en fait sans doute ce dont je vais essayer de vous parler.
Donc, cette conférence va porter sur comment nous faisons les choses
et quelles sont les nouvelles façons dont nous allons les faire à l'avenir.
Maintenant, TED vous envoie beaucoup de spam si vous êtes un conférencier
sur "fais ceci, fais cela" et vous remplissez tous ces formulaires,
et vous ne savez pas vraiment comment ils vont vous décrire,
et tout à coup, j'ai réalisé qu'ils allaient me présenter comme un futuriste.
Et le terme futuriste m'a toujours rendu nerveux,
parce que vous semblez voué à l'échec parce que vous ne pouvez pas vraiment prévoir l'avenir.
Et j'en riais avec mes très intelligents collègues,
et j'ai dit: "Vous savez, eh bien, si je dois parler de l'avenir, c'est quoi?"
Et George Homsey, un gars formidable, a dit: "Oh, l'avenir est étonnant.
C'est tellement plus étrange que tu penses.
Nous allons reprogrammer les bactéries dans ton intestin,
et nous allons faire que ton caca sente la menthe poivrée."
(Rires)
Donc, vous pouvez penser que c'est vraiment fou,
mais il y a des choses assez étonnantes qui se produisent
qui rendent cela possible.
Donc, ce n'est pas mon travail, mais c'est un travail de mes bons amis au MIT.
C'est ce qu'on appelle le registre des pièces biologique standard .
Il est dirigé par Drew Endy et Tom Knight
et quelques autres individus très, très intelligents.
Fondamentalement, ce qu'ils font c'est de considérer la biologie en tant que système programmable.
Littéralement, pensez aux protéines comme à des sous-routines
que vous pouvez enchaîner pour exécuter un programme.
Maintenant, c'est en fait en train de devenir une idée tellement intéressante.
Il s'agit d'un diagramme d'état. C'est un ordinateur extrêmement simple.
Celui-ci est un compteur à deux bits.
Donc, c'est essentiellement l'équivalent informatique de deux interrupteurs.
Et cela est construit par un groupe d'étudiants à Zurich
pour un concours de design en biologie.
Et à partir des résultats de la même compétition l'an dernier,
une équipe d'étudiants de l'Université du Texas a programmé des bactéries
afin qu'elles puissent détecter la lumière et allumer et éteindre.
Donc c'est intéressant dans le sens que vous pouvez maintenant
faire des déclarations conditionnelles dans des matériaux, des structures.
Cette tendance est assez intéressante.
Parce que nous vivions dans un monde où tout le monde disait avec désinvolture,
la forme suit la fonction, mais je crois que j'ai grandi dans un monde
- Vous avez écouté Neil Gershenfeld hier,
J'ai été dans un laboratoire associé à son labo - où c'est vraiment un monde
où l'information définit la forme et la fonction.
J'ai passé six ans à réfléchir à ce sujet,
mais pour vous montrer le pouvoir de l'art sur la science -
il s'agit en fait l'une des bandes dessinées que j'écris. Ce sont les Howtoons.
Je travaille avec un illustrateur fabuleux qui s'appelle Nick Dragotta.
Ca m'a pris six ans au MIT,
et autant de pages que ça pour décrire ce que je faisais,
et il lui a fallu une seule page. Et ceci est notre muse Tucker.
Il s'agit d'un intéressant petit enfant - et sa sœur, Céline -
et ce qu'il fait ici
c'est qu'il observe l'auto-assemblage de ses Cheerios dans son bol de céréales.
Et en fait, vous pouvez programmer l'auto-assemblage des choses,
il commence donc par tremper les bords trempés dans le chocolat,
ce qui change l'hydrophobicité et la hydrophylicité.
En théorie, si vous les programmez suffisamment,
vous devriez être capable de faire quelque chose d'assez intéressant
et de faire une structure très complexe.
Dans ce cas, il a fait une auto-réplication d'une structure complexe en 3D .
Et c'est ce que je pensais depuis longtemps,
car c'est ainsi que nous créons des choses aujourd'hui.
Il s'agit d'une plaquette de silicium, et essentiellement
c'est juste un tas de couches de matière en deux dimensions, un peu comme un mille-feuille.
Le côté caractéristique est - vous savez, les gens diront,
[Pas clair] descendu autour de 65 nanomètres maintenant.
Sur la droite, c'est un radiolaire.
C'est un organisme unicellulaire omniprésent dans les océans.
Et il peu mesurer à peine environ 20 nanomètres,
et c'est une structure 3D complexe .
Nous pourrions faire beaucoup plus avec les ordinateurs et les choses en général
si nous savions comment construire des choses de cette façon.
Le secret de la biologie est, elle inclus du calcul
dans la façon dont elle crée les choses. Donc, cette petite chose ici, la polymérase,
est essentiellement un superordinateur conçu pour la réplication de l'ADN.
Et ce ribosome, ici, est un autre petit ordinateur
qui aide à la traduction des protéines.
J'ai réfléchi à ce sujet
en ce sens que c'est formidable de construire en matériaux biologiques,
Mais peut-on faire des choses semblables ?
Peut-on obtenir un comportement d'auto-réplication ?
Pouvons-nous obtenir qu'une structure complexe 3D s'assemble automatiquement
dans les systèmes inorganiques?
Parce qu'il y a des avantages aux systèmes inorganiques,
comme les semi-conducteurs à grande vitesse, et cetera.
Donc, c'est une partie de mon travail
sur comment faire un système qui s'auto-réplique de façon autonome.
Et cela est une sorte de vengeance de Babbage.
Là vous avez de petits ordinateurs mécaniques.
Ce sont des machines à cinq états.
Donc, ce sont trois interrupteurs alignés.
Dans un état neutre, ils ne se lient pas du tout.
Maintenant, si j'en fais une chaîne, une chaîne de bits,
ils seront en mesure de reproduire.
Nous commençons donc avec blanc, bleu, bleu, blanc.
Ce code, qui va maintenant se copier. De un vient deux,
puis de deux vient trois.
Et donc vous avez ce genre de système de réplication .
C'était un travail fait par Lionel Penrose,
le père de Roger Penrose, le gars des ardoises.
Il a fait beaucoup de ce travail dans les années 60,
et donc beaucoup de cette théorie logique est restée en jachère
quand nous sommes passés à la révolution informatique numérique, mais elle revient à présent.
Alors maintenant, je vais vous montrer l'auto-réplication autonome sans intervention.
Nous avons donc suivi dans la vidéo la chaîne d'entrée,
qui était vert, vert, jaune, jaune, vert.
Nous les avons lancés sur cette table de air hockey.
Vous savez, la science de haut niveau utilise des tables de air hockey -
(Rires)
- Et si vous regardez ça assez longtemps ça vous donne des étourdissements,
mais ce que vous êtes en train de voir, ce sont des copies de cette chaîne d'origine
émergeant de la réserve de pièces que vous avez ici.
Nous avons donc une réplication autonome de chaînes de bits.
Alors, pourquoi vouloir reproduire des chaînes de bits?
Eh bien, il s'avère que la biologie a cet autre mémé très intéressant,
que vous pouvez prendre une chaîne linéaire, ce qui est une chose facile à copier,
et vous pouvez la plier pour en faire arbitrairement une structure complexe en 3D.
Donc j'essayais, vous savez, prendre la version de l'ingénieur :
Peut-on construire un système mécanique dans des matériaux inorganiques
qui fera la même chose?
Donc ce que je vous montre ici, c'est que nous pouvons faire une forme 2D -
la B - assemblée à partir d'une chaîne de composants
qui suivent des règles extrêmement simples.
Et le point de suivre des règles très simple ici,
et les machines d'état incroyablement simple de la conception précédente,
c'est que vous n'avez pas besoin de logique numérique pour faire le calcul.
Et de cette façon, vous pouvez mettre les choses à une bien plus petite échelle que les puces électroniques.
Ainsi, vous pouvez littéralement les utiliser comme les minuscules composants dans le processus d'assemblage.
Donc, Neil Gershenfeld vous a montré cette vidéo, mercredi, je crois,
mais je vais vous la montrer à nouveau.
C'est littéralement la séquence de couleur de ces tuiles.
Chaque couleur différente a une polarité magnétique différente,
et la séquence spécifie de manière unique la structure qui sort.
Maintenant, espérons-le, ceux d'entre vous qui connaissent quoi que ce soit de la théorie des graphes
peuvent regarder ça, et il seront satisfaits
de voir que cela peut aussi faire des structures 3D arbitraires,
et, en fait, vous savez, je peux maintenant prendre un chien, le découper
et puis le remonter ensuite pour en faire une chaîne linéaire
qui se plie à partir d'une séquence. Et maintenant
je peux effectivement définir cet objet en trois dimensions comme une séquence de bits.
Donc, vous savez, c'est un monde très intéressant
quand vous commencez à le regarder un peu différemment.
Et l'univers est un compilateur.
Et je me demande, vous savez, ce que sont les programmes
pour la programmation de l'univers physique ?
Et comment pouvons-nous penser aux matériaux et à la structure,
comme à des problèmes d'information et de calcul ?
Pas seulement lorsque vous connectez un micro-contrôleur à la fin,
mais que la structure et les mécanismes sont la logique, qu'ils sont les ordinateurs.
Ayant totalement absorbé cette philosophie,
j'ai commencé à regarder beaucoup de problèmes un peu différemment.
Avec l'univers pour ordinateur,
vous pouvez regarder cette goutte d'eau
comme ayant effectué les calculs.
Vous définissez une ou deux conditions aux limites, comme la gravité,
la tension de surface, la densité, et cetera, et puis vous appuyez sur exécuter,
et comme par magie, l'univers vous produit une lentille boule parfaite.
Donc, en appliquant ceci au problème
de - donc il y a entre un demi-milliard et un milliard de personnes dans le monde
qui n'ont pas accès à des lunettes à bas prix.
Alors, peut-on faire une machine
qui pourrait faire n'importe quel verre de prescription très vite, sur place ?
Il s'agit d'une machine sur laquelle vous définissez littéralement une condition à la limite.
Si elle est circulaire, vous faites un verre sphérique.
Si elle est elliptique, vous pouvez faire un verre astigmate.
Mettez ensuite une membrane dessus et vous appliquez la pression -
pour que cela fasse partie du programme d'appoint.
Et littéralement, avec seulement ces deux entrées -
donc, la forme de votre condition à la limite et la pression -
vous pouvez définir un nombre infini de verres
qui couvrent toutes les erreurs de réfraction humaine,
de moins 12 à plus huit dioptries, jusqu'à quatre dioptries du cylindre.
Et puis littéralement, vous versez maintenant sur un monomère.
Vous savez, je vais le faire à la Julia Childs ici.
C'est trois minutes de lumière UV.
Et vous inversez la pression sur votre membrane
une fois que c'est cuit. Sortez le.
J'ai vu cette vidéo, mais je ne sais toujours pas si elle va bien finir.
(Rires)
Alors vous inversez cette tendance. C'est un film très vieux,
et avec les nouveaux prototypes, en fait les deux faces sont flexibles,
mais cela vous montrera le principe.
Maintenant que vous avez terminé le verre, vous le faites littéralement sortir.
C'est la collection Yves Klein de l'année prochaine, vous savez, la forme des verres de lunettes.
Et vous pouvez voir que cela a une prescription légère d'environ moins deux dioptries.
Et comme je le tourne vers ce côté, vous verrez que cela a un cylindre ,
et qui a été programmé en -
littéralement dans la physique du système.
Donc, ce genre de réflexion sur la structure en tant que calcul
et la structure en tant qu'information conduit à d'autres choses, comme ça.
C'est quelque chose sur quoi mon équipe à SQUID Labs
travaille en ce moment, appelé corde électronique.
Donc, littéralement, vous pensez à une corde. Elle a une structure très complexe dans sa trame.
Et sans charge, c'est une structure.
Sous une charge différente, c'est une structure différente. Et vous pouvez réellement exploiter ça
en ajoutant un très petit nombre de
fibres conductrices pour effectivement en faire un capteur.
C'est donc maintenant une corde qui connaît la charge sur la corde
à n'importe quel point dans la corde.
Rien qu'en pensant à la physique du monde,
aux matériaux en tant qu'ordinateur,
vous pouvez commencer à faire des choses comme ça.
Je vais enchaîner un peu ici.
Je pense que je vais juste vous dire en passant le genre de choses
que je pense à cet égard.
Une chose qui m'intéresse vraiment dans ce domaine maintenant, comment,
si vous adhérez vraiment à ce point de vue de l'univers en tant qu' ordinateur,
comment pouvons-nous créer des choses dans un sens très général,
et comment pouvons-nous partager la façon dont nous faisons les choses dans un sens général
de la même manière que vous partagez du matériel open source?
Et beaucoup de discussions ici ont épousé les avantages
d'avoir une multitude de personnes pour examiner les problèmes,
partager l'information et travailler sur ces choses ensemble.
Donc, pour un être humain il est facile de se déplacer sur un temps linéaire,
et sauf si Lisa Randall change ça,
nous allons continuer à évoluer dans le temps linéaire.
Cela signifie donc que tout ce que vous faites ou que vous créez
vous produisez une série d'étapes -
et je pense que Lego dans les années 70 a mis dans le mille,
et ils l'ont fait le plus élégamment du monde.
Mais ils peuvent vous montrer comment construire des choses en séquence.
Donc, je réfléchis, comment peut-on généraliser
la façon dont nous faisons toutes sortes de choses,
pour se retrouver avec ce genre de truc, vous voyez?
Et je pense que cela s'applique très largement - à de nombreux concepts.
Vous savez, hier, Cameron Sinclair a dit,
"Comment puis-je obtenir que chacun collabore à la conception
globalement pour créer des logements pour l'humanité? "
Et si vous avez vu Amy Smith,
elle parle de la façon dont vous obtenez des étudiants du MIT
qu'ils travaillent avec les communautés en Haïti.
Et je pense que nous devons redéfinir et repenser
la façon dont nous définissons la structure et les matériaux et les assemblages,
afin que nous puissions vraiment partager l'information
sur la façon dont vous faites ces choses, d'une manière plus profonde
et bâtir sur les codes sources des uns et des autres pour la structure.
Je ne sais pas encore exactement comment le faire,
mais, vous savez, j'y pense activement.
Donc, vous savez, cela conduit à des questions
comme, est-ce un compilateur ? Est-ce une sous-routine ?
Des choses intéressantes comme ça.
Peut-être que je deviens un peu trop abstrait, mais vous savez,
c'est le genre de - pour revenir à nos personnages de bande dessinée -
c'est en quelque sorte l'univers, ou une vue différente de l'univers
qui je pense prévaudra dans l'avenir -
de la biotechnologie aux matériaux d'assemblage. C'était formidable d'entendre Bill Joy.
Ils commencent à investir dans la science des matériaux,
mais ce sont des choses nouvelles dans la science des matériaux.
Comment pouvons-nous transformer l'information réelle et la structure réelle en idées nouvelles,
et voir le monde d'une manière différente ? Et ça ne sera pas du code binaire
qui définit les ordinateurs de l'univers -
c'est une sorte d'ordinateur analogique.
Mais c'est certainement une vision nouvelle et intéressante du monde.
Je suis allé trop loin. Donc,on dirait bien que c'est terminé.
J'ai probablement une ou deux minutes de questions,
ou je peux montrer - je pense qu'ils ont également dit que je faisais des trucs extrêmes
dans l'introduction, je dois peut-être expliquer ça.
Alors peut-être que je vais le faire avec cette courte vidéo.
Donc, il s'agit d'un cerf-volant de 900 mètres carrés,
qui se trouve être également une surface d'énergie minimale.
Donc, pour en revenir à la goutte, à nouveau,
en pensant à l'univers d'une manière nouvelle.
Il s'agit d'un cerf-volant conçu par un gars nommé Dave Kulp.
Et pourquoi voudriez-vous un cerf-volant de 900 mètres carrés?
Donc, c'est un cerf-volant de la taille de votre maison.
Et vous voulez ça pour remorquer des bateaux très vite.
J'ai donc travaillé un peu là-dessus, aussi,
avec deux ou trois autres types.
Mais, vous savez, c'est une autre façon de regarder le -
si on se met à nouveau dans l'abstrait,
c'est une structure qui est définie par la physique de l'univers.
Vous pouvez tout simplement l'accrocher comme un drap de lit,
mais là encore, le calcul de toute la physique
vous donne la forme aérodynamique.
Et donc vous pouvez réellement presque doubler la vitesse de votre bateau
avec des systèmes comme ça. Donc, c'est un autre aspect intéressant de l'avenir.
(Applaudissements)